Batch payment, batch!
It's really all you hear network specialists talking about nowadays
Almost as if they were trying to say something to you
My name is Colt McCannless, and the fact that they are
We all know that networking is the biggest criminal
When it comes to battery drain on mobile devices
I mean, take into account the waves of broadcast on any of your phones
After a request, it will wait for an additional time of about 20 to 60 seconds
Keeps the chip shaky, drains the power in case of a server response only
If nothing is returned, only then will it move to sleep mode
In the worst case scenario, your application can end up in a position
Each of the network requests activates cellular transmission waves
It pays to keep it active over time
Assembly is the best way to link these requests together
So that you only have to pay the cost of activation and keep the device active once
But the big question here is, how will you actually assemble?
Well, first understand that any requests created as a result of a user's work
Generally need to be processed now
Everything else though, is quite a game of justice
Basically, if there is even a slight chance that the request will be delayed
It will not cause users to throw their phones out of the window
Then you have to think about it
Now from the code point of view, it is the easiest way to implement the assembly
Are essentially intercepting applications
Rather than immediately implemented
We store them in a queue of actions to be implemented in the future
This can be as simple as a Queue object or as complex as a content provider
To transform them into a sequential form to disk
In case you are worried about losing them when the application is terminated
But here's the hard part
How do we know when to send these pending orders?
Well, you can wait until you reach a minimum
Such as 10 requests or anything and then launch your list Activate broadcast waves from dormancy and send data
It is a very accurate way to address the problem
But the truth is that the system does a lot of other things in the background
Before reaching the threshold point
Cell broadcast waves will be activated to complete some other tasks
Therefore, it is very logical to try and carry out these operations when they occur
Basically, you can set up this code to give the application a reverse call
Any time the network devices are turned on
When that happens, go ahead and launch the waiting line.
But things may become a bit more complicated
What if you want to wait until you connect to a Wi-Fi network
Or connect it to a power source?
Or something crazy,
Such as you want to wait until the user is not riding a bike or not in a car anymore
This is exactly why you need to use a GCM network administrator
This is the Google Store Services API which helps to schedule network oriented tasks
And handle the assembly for you.
This greatly simplifies the implementation of common patterns
Such as waiting for connection and networking, retrying network attempts and retreating.
Basically, all the good things you need with one useful API
Now, if you do not know what the profile looks like for your application
Or you are at a bad point
Check out the Network Monitor tool within the Android Studio
This tool will help you to know how many times incoming and outgoing requests occur
The size of each request
Assembly is one of the basic techniques
Which can improve the performance of your applications to users
But it is not the only networking technology you need to know
This is why you need to check the rest of the content of Android performance patterns
Do not forget to join our community on Google+ as well
So stay calm, type your code, and always remember, performance is important.